Just before we wrap up here, it'd be good to go over landscape visibility masks for
if you want to mask anything out in your landscape.
So landscape visibility mask allow you to remove a visual collision mesh of your landscape
so you can subterrain structures like caves or secret bases, anything where you want to
kind of dig into the landscape a little bit.
So it's achieved by placing a landscape visibility node in your landscape material.
And then when applied to your landscape, you can then paint in the visibility of where
you want to pass through.
So to create this, you need to make a new material or use an existing material, but
we need the landscape visibility mask node, which we can add maybe to an existing landscape
material if we want.
So we need to set the blend mode to masked in this instance, and it'll only work with
masked materials.
So make sure your blend mode is set to mask there.
And then just select the landscape in the editor viewport and look for the landscape
whole material and apply it in that section there.
Then when we have the landscape tools open, we can go to the visibility section and we
can add or remove visibility using the paint tools as we would with the terrain tools,
and you can add or remove landscape sections when painting.